there's a sergeant I I I'm assuming he's
retired now and wouldn't mind me telling
the story but I I promise that this can
be um um researched not on Google but
the these people are around because
there too many of them not to too many
witnesses so this is the opening scene
of the movie about the actor prepares
yeah so I've spent all this time and I'm
you know it's interesting and and this
guy would let me ride around just with
him
and we' do warrants you know he'd say
well you got a warrant on this guy you
want to do this you so one day we're
rolling around and I was wearing a the
uh the
windbreaker and I had a uh a 4in 38
caliber that I would keep underneath it
here and we um we see these guys
standing out in front of a van in front
of a little house down in a
um in the South Central Los Angeles area
and I won't say which color but they're
wearing either red or blue MH and he
says uh what you say Jack him up the
shar's office tactically they would I
don't I don't know if they still do but
they would either either you were over
the car or down on your knees fingers
interlaced and he would be behind and he
had them all like that my job was to
secure the van that so there's the house
the van the guys so he's one police
officer one sheriff's
deputy and an
actor and so I've got my flashlight
again like this and I go per training to
the the blind spot which is between the
back panel windows and the side panel
windows and I'm got the light and I know
probably the drugs you've been told
they're going to be up inside the the
door handle or they're going to be here
and like the night before I'd also CL
you see you see a gun you say gun right
and I come and I'm going to do what you
you'll know what this is but a quick
peek right so nobody's reflexes are fast
enough if the Wall's here I can get
around here and see what's going on
before you're going to be able to pull a
trigger or
something well I pick the night cuz I go
like this and I go from the blind spot I
do the quick Peak and a g is point right
my face I say gun now he has five guys
or about five guys and they're all prone
out facing the street not pred out
they're on their knees and he can't get
out of the line of fire of that van yeah
I'm now back under in
cover he's on his radio and he's you
know calling the
calvary and all of these guys the calary
who will come they know knew me because
some of them had been training me
yeah and he kicks each of the guys who's
on their knees he kicks them down on the
ground CU he doesn't want any of he
hasn't even gotten to search them all
yet and so they're all on the ground
they're complaining somewhat but they're
on the ground his gun is on
them and suddenly a lot of police cars
are showing
up and I'm seeing faces that I know and
they're giving me hand
signals they want me to what I read is
now some time has passed they want me to
uh um do one more quick peat because
that person could have moved just to
identify where which part of the van cuz
they got me they don't want to hurt yeah
they got him in the line of
fire so I might now just peek it and
again this the in 1980s and reconfirm
position and get under the van and stay
there because we they that [__] to do
yeah and now it's daylight cuz now
there's a helicopter over this whole
scene right and W
and I
check and the gun of course was still
pointing at me because it was my
reflection oh
[__] [__] and all of this chaos
was because I saw a gun oh [__] that was
uh yeah oh my God so you think I got
ragged for a little while on that oh
[__] that's the [__] greatest yeah
for years sometimes I'd run into some
guy with a mustache he'd say you know I
was I was a young cop at that time I was
there that night
that yeah you know it's going to destroy
I'm never going to let an actor going to
ride along again now that I've given
this interview so [__] good oh it's
so good the most humiliating moment
anybody could ever have wow dude holy
[__] it's all about how you get back up
John yeah there you go brother there you
go yeah hey you you have time for a
couple more no sure what do you think
about movies today like where do you
think we're at now what's better about
Show Business now what's worse uh what's
the state uh are there truth tellers now
uh are there artists right now that you
really admire um what do you think about
it because I I I just don't know that we
for me at least from where I sit and I
think of you
and the things that you've done and and
and of this like generation of of of the
greats of my heroes and I don't really
know who's who else is out there I I'm
I'm tremendously uh worried about it and
I'm worried about the attention span of
the audience I'm worried about what
people the [__] that's being me made the
[__] that I'm reading um I just like to
know what your thoughts were well okay
let's start with the good stuff okay
right
so you know know we're sitting
here most
certainly you know not without child
both and my having stumbled on that
great conversation the two of you had
you
know B VOD katonic at night and turning
on the
television and um I just saw have you
seen the play that he's done it well so
I think that that's a Zone um that would
have been
extraordinary at any time in cinema or
theater so there are people operating at
a really high level when I mentioned the
Stephen Fry thing you know part
of he talks about young people being
very anxious because they don't know how
to
operate how to navigate what they can
say what they can't
say he talks about
diversity and that those who are put
pushing diversity
um are pushing it in a very undiverse
way you you know you you can't be
diverse in your
language um your
behavior it's a kind
of you know I don't want to be
necessarily officially associated with a
lot of people who maybe in this topic I
agree about a lot of it but um I
um I think we're doing ourselves an
incredible
disservice
by thinking in that way which will make
us popular um amongst the
loudest it's less
colorful and it's less
challenging and when things are um
Limited in you know through the kind
of um uh what would you call it pure
pressure and careers at
risk
um when people can be pigeonhed as less
than um as easily as
today you're it's going to affect the
movies it's going to create a a a an
invisible sense of
self-censorship um it's going to
decrease the magic and so so we're
giving the magic to
[Music]
machines